[Müzik]
Merhabalar
önce kırmızı noktada durmak gerekiyor
Ben bir kere daha terlikse çıktım şurada
durmuşum YouTube'da var ama ben
görünmüyorum 15 dakika ses var o yüzden
en büyük korkum burada duramamak
konuşurken ben elektrik elektronik
mühendisiyim internet üzerine
çalışıyorum Bitcoin ile aranır
bitcoin'i Duyanlara Kaldırabilir mi
zarar edenler
Bunu bilen var mı
akü
hemen googlelayanlar var mı aranızda
sınavda hızlı kopya çekenler
bu geometri bilmeyen geometri bilmeyen
giremez anlamına geliyor platonun
okulunda yazıyor Platon gibi bu kadar
devlete insana topluma kafa yormuş
birisi
okulunun girişine Neden geometri ile
ilgili bir söz yazmıştır diye böyle
biraz düşünmüştüm
sonra geometri hikayeleri aklıma geldi
benim geometim çok kötüdür Bu arada
üniversite sınavında full yanlış yaptım
sonra 15 yıl sonra bir daha girdim yine
geometrik atarım
geometri noktayla başlıyor biliyorsunuz
Ha Burada geçişleri yapamamış
animasyonlarda sıkıntı var Ben
söyleyeyim nokta ile başlıyor 2 noktayı
bir araya getiriyoruz ilk ders bu daha
sonra bir sürü şey Öğreniyoruz işte
üçgenler kare açıortay kenarortay falan
derken aslında o kadar değişik şeyler
öğreniyoruz ki sanki bu
iki noktayı bir araya getirmenin önemi
biraz azalıyor
ama aslında bütün yaptığımız şey iki
noktayı bir araya getirebilme becerisi
Az sonra bir sürü teknolojilerden
bahsedeceğim Benim 20 yıldır uğraştığım
şeyler lisede başlamıştım bende Bizim
sınıf 24 kişiydi 21 Doktor oldu Biri
Şair oldu Biri takılıyor bir de ben
varım
ama en mutlu benimdir Muhtemelen Çünkü
gerçekten 13 yaşından beri internet
üzerine kafa yoruyordum ve sevdiğim işi
yapıyorum
ve bu 20 yıl Aslında şöyle geçtim Benim
için yaşımdan dolayı webbinin son
evresine yakalandım ve bir dediğimiz
şeyi Az sonra tanımlayacağım Ama genel
olarak statik Durgun Bir internet Siz
izliyorsunuz sadece bilgi alıyorsunuz
ardından ve
dibine kadar gördüm ya bir sürü kitap
yazdım ekmek yedim falan Hepiniz de
içindesiniz sosyal ağlar sosyal medya
vesaire ve şu an ve 3 dediğimiz evrenin
inşası için uğraşıyoruz Bununla ilgili
teknoloji derneğimiz var ve Türkiye'de
dünyada birçok ülkeye göre ön planda
çalışmalar yapıyoruz
Aslında bu 20 yılım şöyle
özetleyebilirim işte bunlar üzerine
çalıştım Yapay Zeka sosyal medya
nesnelerin interneti oyun geliştirme
Seo mobil uygulama ve bunları şimdi
anlatsam sıkılırsınız çok karışık şeyler
ama şöyle bir şey var çok geriye çekilip
baktığımda Aslında iki noktayı
birbiriyle birleştirmeye çalıştığımı
fark ettim yani geometrinin İlk
dersindeki şey mesela Yapay Zeka
dediğimiz de burada bir yapay zeka
oluşturuyoruz ve o insan bir insanı
onunla birleştirmeye çalışıyoruz veya
sosyal medya dediğimiz şey aslında bir
deney gibi düşünün çünkü 90'larda Eğer
deneseydi ki
100 milyonlarca insan birbirine mesaj
atabilecek Kaos olur mu diye bir anket
yapsalardı sokaktaki herkes Kaos olur
derdi ama biz bu deneyi yaşıyoruz şu
anda bu iki ucu birleştirmeye
çalışıyoruz ayeti de nesneleri
birbiriyle birleştiriyoruz Yani bir
mikrodalga fırınına bir çamaşır
makinesine konuşturursak ne olur
birbirlerine söyleyecek bir şeyleri var
mıdır veya bir kombinin veya bir çamaşır
makinesinin insana veya bir yapay
bir çamaşır makinesine bir sürü karmaşık
şeyi düşünüyoruz oyun dediğimiz şeyde de
yine bir uçta oyun Endüstrisi var burada
Üstadı var oyunlar var bir tarafta da
insan var ve bu ikisini bir araya
getirmeye çalışıyoruz
oyunlaştırma ile birçok alanı bunun
içerisine katmaya çalışıyoruz seo'da
arama motorları milyonlarca 100
milyonlarca internet sitesi ile arama
motorlarını konuşturmaya çalışıyoruz hep
iki nokta var ve bu iki noktayı doğru
şekilde bağlamaya çalışıyoruz mobil
uygulamada da mobil cihazları ve bu
süreçte
ve bir dediğimiz evre Aslında şöyle bir
evreydi internet siteleri vardı O
internet sitelerine giren kişileri
görüyordu internet sitesindeki bilgiyi
alıyorduk ama internet sitesine kimin
girdiğini bilmiyorduk ve giren kişiler
aslında içerik ekleyemiyordu ve
dolayısıyla karanlıktan bakan gözler
gibiydi burada 2000'lerin başında
internet kullanan var mı
2001 falan 2001
aralarda ben 2002'de ilk bilgisayar
virüsünü yazmıştım
o yıllarda baya hızlıydı internet benim
sitemde hacklemişlerdi Ben de Bayağı da
eklemiştim yavaş yavaş normalleşti bu
evrede Aslında internet siteleri sadece
sayaçlara bakıyordu yani kaç kişinin
girdiğini görüyorduk sadece kim olduğunu
bilmiyorduk ve çevresinde
Bu gözler birbirini görmeye başladı bu
gözlerin birbirini görmesi Yani bir
markayla ben etkileşim kurabilirim Annem
köydeki Düğün fotoğrafını beğenebilir
veya işte linktende bir kişi iş
bulabilir vesaire ama burada bir tane
ana problemimiz var ve bizim şu anda
derneğin odaklandığı şey de bu arada
üçüncü bir göz var ve her şeyi izliyor
her şeyi değerlendiriyor YouTube'a video
yüklediğinizde sizi ne kadar para
kazanacağınıza YouTube karar veriyor
tiktok'ta veya Facebook'ta bir
profiliniz olduğunda çok fazla takipçiye
çıktığında istediği anda Facebook
Profilinizi kapatabiliyor
biz sizin elinizde değil yani bunu
ortadan kaldırabilir miyiz düşüncesi ile
aslında şu anda odaklandığımız şey ve 3
ama bence sunumun çarptığı noktalarından
biri Burası ki bu lisede öğrenirken bunu
duysaydım herhalde Dünyam çok değişirdi
ve 3'te çözmeye çalıştığımız şey güven
sorunu şöyle geçenlerde bir
dökümantasyon inceliyorum proje kendini
anlatırken şöyle diyor kendini övmek
için güvenilmez diyor güvenilmez bir
proje Çünkü Güven dediğimiz şey aslında
bütün problemlerin kökündeki şey
teknoloji bağlamında Güven dediğimiz şey
Siz Facebook'a güveniyorsunuz WhatsApp'a
güveniyorsunuz Bilgilerinize girip
birinin bakmadığına güveniyorsunuz ve
güven olduğu sürece beraberinde
kardeşini getiriyor O kardeşi de şüphe
biz şüpheyi nasıl ortadan kaldırabiliriz
teknolojide odaklandığımız şey bu
şüpheyi nasıl ortadan kaldırabiliriz
şüpheyi ortadan kaldırmak için yapmamız
gereken şey aslında güveni de ortadan
kaldırma güvenmememiz gerekiyor Yani
nasıl güvenmeyeceğiz peki bu sistemi
nasıl kurgulayabiliriz yani vaktimiz
Olsaydı keşke soru cevap şeklinde
gitseydik Çünkü burada zihninizi
zorlamanız çok önemli şöyle yaparız bir
bilgiyi tek bir yerde tutmayız
milyonlarca yerde tutarız milyonlarca
yerde tuttuğumuzda artık Tek bir kişiye
güvenmek zorunda olmayız Bu sistemin
adına ne diyoruz bilen var mı
blok
sensörü ile tek bir yerde veriyi
tutmuyoruz bir tane örnek yapalım mesela
her nokta nokta kendi bacağından asılır
buradaki Nokta nokta yerine ne gelecek
koyundan başka bir düşüncesi olan var mı
insan Tamam başka
Diyelim ki biz bunu sorduk burada yüz
kesi var
99 kişi koyun dedi bir kişi insan dedi
Burada birisi şüpheli kim
bilgisayar anlamında baktığınızda o
insan diyen kişi hatalı bir işlem
yapıyor Dolayısıyla Biz Tek bir kişiye
güvenmiyoruz güveni dağıtık hale
getiriyoruz ve bu şekilde bunu
sağlıyoruz bunu sağladığımız zaman ne
yapıyoruz Aslında bunu sağladığımız
zaman ve bu bilgileri bir zincirle
birbirine bağladığımız zaman blok
zinciri oluşturuyoruz ve bu blok zincir
üzerinden bir sürü şey geçiriyoruz
bunlar ilk bakışta teknik gelebilir
çünkü bunlar onlarca yıl
bilgisayarcıların uğraşarak yaptığı
şeyler ama özetle şuraya geldiğimizde
görüyoruz ki biz bir köprü yapıyoruz bu
köprünün özelliği şu
diyelim ki ben işte Kayhan hocam Ercan
Hoca mı bir şey göndereceğim bunu üçüncü
bir Otoritenin gözetimi altında yapmak
zorunda değilim Ben 10 dolar
göndereceksem Kayhan Hocam'a 10 doları
göndereceğim bu uçtan uca gönderilecek
bunun için Facebook'un iznini almama
gerek yok başka bir şeyiniz ne anlama
geliyor benim oyunda bir pelerinim varsa
ve bu pelerini Ercan hocaya göndermek
istiyorsam bunu hiç kimsenin izni
olmadan gönderebilmem lazım işte bu
sistemleri nasıl kurarız sorusunun
cevabını bu köprüyü yapıyoruz ve bu
köprünün üzerinden şimdilerde ne
geçiriyoruz ilk başta Kripto paraları
geçiriyoruz Çünkü belki de insanlık
tarihi boyunca en önemli şeylerden biri
bir değer saklama Paranın değeri gitgide
düşüyor veya bir afet oluyor göç
ediyorsunuz başka bir sürü sorun
çıkabiliyor bunun için işte altın gibi
değerli madenler var ama alternatif
dijitalde de bir karşılığı olması lazım
Çünkü altın programlanabilir bir şey
değil yani bir İkisi de oyunda pelerin
var diye bir gram bakamazsınız diye
Burada daha farklı bir araca ihtiyacımız
var ilk Kripto paraları buradan
geçiriyoruz Köprüden sonra diyoruz ki
sadece Niye Kripto paraları geçirelim
burada sanat eserleri üretelim farklı
materyaller üretelim Mesela bir
üniversiteye hazırlık kitabını Bu
köprünün üzerinden geçelim ben de bir
kitap var ve onu sana vermek istiyorum
Hiçbir Otoritenin denetim altında
olmadan bunu geçirelim enfli olarak
devam ediyoruz dağları geçirelim diyoruz
ve hakları buradan aktaralım yani bir
referandumu bu şekilde yapabiliriz
üçüncü bir Otoritenin gözetim olmadan
bir referandum yapabiliriz okulda bir
seçim yapabiliriz vesaire
ve Diyoruz ki bütün finansal
enstrümanları buradan geçirebiliriz
ardından oyunlardaki bütün varlıkları bu
köprü üzerinden geçirebiliriz diyoruz
burada Game dediğimiz şey tanımıyoruz ve
bu devam ediyor
ama burada şöyle bir sorun var bizim
gibi işte git dedikleri bilgisayarla bu
kadar ilgilenen kişilerin sorunları
annemin sorunları olmayabilir annemin
babamın da sorunlarıyla Yani bütün
toplumun sorunlarıyla uğraşmadığımız
sürece Teknoloji çok anlamlı değil ve
burada artık kronik insanlığın kronik
sorunlarını ele almaya başlıyoruz ve
artık yani yavaş yavaş blok zinciri
Endüstrisi insanların kronik
sorunlarıyla ilgilenmeye başlıyor mesela
eğitimle ilgileniyoruz
konuşma dinledim beş konuşmanın her
birine az çok blok zinciri
eklemleyebiliriz Yani ilk konuşmacımız
Çiğdem Hanım'da Çiğdem Hanım'ın işte
ürettikleri defileyi Biz meteors de
yapabiliriz nft haline getirebiliriz o
kadınların emeğini tüm dünyadan
fonlayabiliriz ardından Berk konuştu
Berk'in çalışmasını okuldaki
çalışmalarını finanse etme noktasında
blok zinciri kullanabiliriz ardından
Kayhan hocam konuştu
görüntülü Hanım konuştu güntülü hanımın
istedi dünyadaki bu yapmak istediği tüm
çalışmaları aynı şekilde fonlayabiliriz
ve oradaki üstündeki ülkede gezdiği elde
ettiği şeylerden bir dijital Sanat
Galerisi oluşturup dijital Sanat
Galerisi üzerinden diğer
yapacağı Gezileri fonlayabiliriz
ardından Kayhan hocam konuştu Okula
dönüştürürken işte şimdi söyleyeceğim
şeyler kullanabiliriz ardından
münazarayla ilgili bir konuşma oldu yine
münazara noktasında insanların münazara
etmek kabiliyetlerini değerlendir Kent
finansal bağışları motivasyon olarak
kullanabiliriz falan filan yani
istediğiniz alana bunları
uygulayabiliriz
eğitimde de işte Ne yapıyoruz Mesela
sizin projeniz var Nasıl finanse
edeceksiniz birinin kapısını mı çalmak
zorunda sahip ekosistem sizi finanse
edecek işte Berk diyor ki ben
blockchain'le ilgileniyorum okulda
blockchain'in topluluğu kuruyorsan
buradan finanse edileceksin şu an
Türkiye'de 74 tane blockchain topluluğu
var Neredeyse en çok alanda topluluk
olan konulardan biri bloktayım veya
öğretmenlerin ürettiği içeriklerin
finansal motivasyonu nasıl sağlanacak
çoğu öğretmen YouTube'a video çekiyor
Sonra bırakıyor Niye Çünkü bir gelir
elde etmiyor sürdürülebilirliği yok biz
bunların hepsini Kripto ekosistemiyle
sağlayabiliriz
kimlikleri buraya taşıyabiliriz
kimlikleri bu mekanizmanın
adını aklınızda tutabilirsiniz kepçe
internetten bakabilirsiniz Biz burada
bütün kimlikleri blok zincirde tutup o
köprü üzerinden bir kimliği getiriyoruz
tapu kaydına bir nüfus cüzdanı bilgisini
ve bir siteye hacklediğinizde o sitedeki
kullanıcı adı şifreler karşınıza
çıkmıyor hiçbir işinize yaramayan
kilitler çıkıyor blok zincirle artık
bunu sağlayıp sitelerin hacklenmesindeki
veri sızmalarını önleyebiliyoruz
robotları buraya bağlayabiliyoruz ya bir
mamematik düşünün Türkiye'de
orada bakıyorsunuz 3 tane sokak köpeği
var sistemden görüyorsunuz Rusya'dan bir
Kripto ile bağış yapıyor ve oradan
mamamatikten mama düşüyor robotları tüm
dünyada bir robot ekonomisi oluşturarak
robotları tüm dünyanın finansal
sistemini Entegre ediyoruz Aynı şekilde
nesneleri de Entegre ediyoruz ve Belki
bir robot burs vermeye başlıyor
öğrencilere Hatta 10 öğrenciye veriyor
programlıyoruz gibi
Buna da robot diye bakabilirsiniz çok
önemli bir konu ve biz burada her şey
depolayabiliriz işte meteorers'deki tüm
varlıklarınızı 3 boyutlu sanal evrendeki
evlerinizi ve diğer her şeyi
depolayabiliriz dosyalarınızı
tek yapmanız gereken bazı anahtar
kelimeleri Google'a yazıp dibine kadar
araştırmak
veya Biz burada bütün gizlilik
katmanlarını artırabiliyoruz Yani
diyelim ki ben bu noktadan bu noktaya
bir şey göndermek istiyorum ama bir
sistem çıktı bir göz olarak bunu
denetlemeye çalışıyor bulmaya çalışıyor
ben bir gizli katmanı daha ekleyip
tekrar gönderebiliyorum
Bunun için de bir sürü proje üretiliyor
sosyal ağlarda bir içerik ürettiniz bir
paylaşım yaptınız Örneğin bu tedx'in
paylaşımını yaptığımızda ne olacak
Instagram'da 30 kişi like tuşuna basıp
gidecek veya 300 kişi 3000 kişi Ama
şunun olması gerekirdi Mesela şöyle bir
sistemi 10 yıl sonra kurgulayabileceğiz
Fethiye'ye değer katan bir iş ve
Fethiye'de yaşayan insanların tıklayıp
doğrudan sizi finanse edebileceği bir
sistemi kurgulayacağız yapacağız bunları
Safi bunu test ediyor şu anda
bakabilirsiniz yani beğen butonu gibi
baş gönder butonu olacak Eğer 90'larda
deseydiniz ki Bir kişi günde 150 kişiye
kalp gönderecek çok saçma gelirdi mesela
100 erkek Bir erkek günde 100 erkeğe
kalp gönderecek deseydiniz muhafazakar
toplumlar özellikle çok garip gelirdi
ama şu an yapıyoruz yani ve 100 kişiye
para göndereceğiz 100 kere de size para
gönderecek her gün her gün bunu
bankacılık sisteminde yapamayız
bankacılık sistemi Hayalini bile kuramaz
Şu an bunu ve substrojen
sitelerde ürettiğiniz her şeye direkt
başlık gönder butonuna çıkıyor
iletişim kısmında da yine
örnek bir proje söyleyeceğim xxm
Messenger Artık WhatsApp tarzı
uygulamalara güvenmek zorunda olmamamız
için noktadan noktaya mesajlaşma
platformları
platformlarını tasarlıyoruz ve bu
platformlarla aslında finansal
teknolojiyi de Entegre ediyoruz mesela
telegram'da dediniz ki şu an örnek
veriyorum telegram'da dediniz ki Ben 10
sınıfım
Fethiye'deyim işte fen lisesi'ndeyim
Ne diyelim işte kimya çalışıyorum gazlar
konusunda takıldım bana yardımcı olacak
birini bul hemen lokasyondan tarıyor
buluyor diyor size iletişime
geçirebilirim ama bana ödeme yap çok
düşük bir ödeme 5 lira nasıl yapacağım
hemen orada cüzdanı bağlayıp Kripto ile
yapacaksın olay bitecek bizim şu an
tasarladığımız platformlardan biri bir
kitap alıyorsun öğrencisin kitabı
okuyorsun işim bitti Tekrar satışa
koyuyorsun ve satıyorsun her satışta ilk
kitabın üreticisine belli bir komisyon
gidiyor
gibi gibi yani 18 dakikada ne kadar
anlatabilirim bilmiyorum ama biraz
zihninizi açtığımı düşünüyorum bu
teknoloji konusunda yani her yere Biz
bunu sokabiliyoruz ve biz her şeyi
yeniden düşünüyoruz Burada her şey bunu
dışarıda bana sorabilirsiniz Buğra abi
Çok abuk bir konu var hadi buna da blogs
zincir Entegre diye yanıma
gelebilirsiniz
Ben iddialıyım bu konuda biz bu
çalışmaları yaparken Tabii motivasyon
kaynaklarımız var Ben bir tanesini Bugün
size söyleyeceğim bitireceğim bizim
motivasyon kaynaklarımızdan biri yayayı
kusamam bu güncellenmemiş hali
güncellenmiş sunumu koymamış Arkadaşlar
orada resmi de var bakabilirsiniz
sadece noktaları kullanarak sanat
eserleri ortaya çıkarıyor bu onun
çalışmalarından biri çok farklı
noktaları bir araya getirerek mükemmel
bir bütünlük sağlıyor ve kusama diyor ki
noktalar yalnız kalamaz bizim yapmaya
çalıştığımız şey de bu bize dahil olmak
isteyen yani teknolojiyi üretmeye dahil
olmak isteyen insanlara da şunu söylemek
istiyoruz biz noktaları bir araya
getirmeye çalışıyoruz bir tekne optimiz
bakış açımız var Yani şöyle bakmıyoruz
Yapay Zeka geldi insanların sonu geldi
robotik geldi İşte İnsanlığın Sonu geldi
blok zincir geldi devletlerin sonu geldi
Biz böyle bakmıyoruz biz teknolojiyi
geliştiriyoruz ve eğer bir problem varsa
o problemi de yine teknoloji
geliştirerek çözmeyi düşünüyoruz Ve bunu
yaparken de en büyük gücünü şu;
biliyoruz ki şu kırmızı noktanın üstünde
dünyada bir sürü insan var Keşfedilmemiş
ve biz onları bir araya getirmeye
çalışıyoruz
Teşekkürler Dinlediğiniz
[Alkış]
[Müzik]